hey 42 here there's something timeless
and romantic about living on the ragged
edge of civilization whether you prefer
the American Old West the final frontier
of space or somewhere in between the
fort's of living in roguish freedom is
certainly appealing to many if you are
hoping to find somewhere free from the
shackles of law in our world today here
are some places you might want to
investigate on the border between
Afghanistan and Pakistan sits an area
known as on governed Afghanistan and it
is just that on government at least to
some extent more officially known as the
federally administered tribal areas it
provides a great opportunity to
experience all the dangers and thrills
of the Old West in the modern era whilst
officially under the jurisdiction of
Pakistan federal government the areas
are considered semi-autonomous which
means that they are bound more by tribal
laws on the frontier crimes regulations
that Pakistan has put over them
basically the law of the land is
whatever the local tribes in warlords
make is out of it when the Supreme Court
of Pakistan refuses to deal with the
region you just know it a dodgy area
seven tribal districts also known as
agencies divide the land with six
frontier regions though they are
represented in the Parliament of
Pakistan by elected representatives the
tribal districts have no problem with
rejecting parliamentary resolutions that
they don't approve of surprisingly
support for the Pakistani military is
high amongst two tribes with nearly 80%
approving of an eventual military
government for now the federally
administered tribal areas remain a
hotbed of militant activity thanks in no
small part to the lack of control which
Pakistan wields over the region if you
fancy rubbing soldiers with outlaws
brigands and warlords then be sure to
book the next available flight
if however Sun dunes and open spaces are
more to your liking
then you're going to love the Western
Sahara it has the honour of being one of
the most sparsely populated territories
in the world
with around two people per square
kilometer based on best estimates with
all that space it's simply a daunting
prospect for anyone government to
control it the Western Sahara region was
considered a Spanish colony until the
late 20th century after which Morocco
and Mauritania fought with the natives
our Hari people for the right to the
land
Mauritania soon gave or leaving Morocco
to claim the most valuable portions
whilst the Sahara people were left with
vast tracts of barren desert despite
Morocco's tenuous grasp on the region
the United Nations refuses to recognize
their claim instead they considered the
Western Sahara to be a
non-self-governing territory due to the
question of whether Spain had adequately
decolonized the area when they cut ties
and left for now if you're interested in
herding camels with the Sahara people
and hiding among the dunes it seems no
one knows what laws actually apply to
the area or how to enforce them best to
take advantage of the situation whilst
it lasts if you were to commit a crime
out there that locals won't even know
who to report you to nevermind
prosecution with the region's lack of
laws mainly attributed to political
negligence and a general mindset of wow
this area is so large and unpopulated
who actually gives what I imagine you
could probably get away with quite a lot
in this vast expanse of barren desert if
living the pirate's life when the high
seas appeals to you grab yourself a boat
and head out to international waters
territorial waters for any nation only
extends 22 kilometers out from the shore
you aren't truly free until you move
through the continuous zone which sounds
like a really cool science fiction movie
but it's not it's an area which extends
in over 22 kilometers beyond territorial
waters for any country and even then if
you're caught engaging in egregious acts
of piracy any nation has the ability to
bring you to justice well there's a
whole lot of water out there unless you
attract an awful lot of attention to
yourself you're just another speck on
the horizon there is something magical
about the high
sieze since the very first ships the
idea of sailing the open ocean has
inspired generations of artists spawning
beautiful paintings books and even
movies to apply laws to such an unruly
stretch of water would almost be an
insult to what is one of Earth's last
true remaining wildernesses
international waters are regulated out
of necessity in our modern world but
enforcing the rules is an impossible
task for the world's government thus the
world's oceans remain one of the last
truly lawless places on earth as the
great Hugo Grotius said in the early
17th century people from all nations
have a right to the waterways of the
world
he called his right mer LeBaron latin
for the free sea and his book by the
same name laid the groundwork for the
concept of international waters as we
know them today so set sail for the high
seas and celebrate the freedom Grotius
championed centuries passed in January
of 1991 Somalia suddenly found its
central government dissolved as it
plunged into a bloody civil war that
still rages on to this day in the two
decades that followed anarchy rule today
as warlords fought amongst themselves
for the opportunity to rule small
sections of this fragmented country that
have since been several attempts to
re-establish order in the region
starting with the short-lived
transitional national government in 2000
and most recently of the federal
government of Somalia in 2012 only time
will tell whether the latter is
effective though the formation of a
parliament and the election of an
official president does lend some
momentum to the effort meanwhile the
region remains fractured the concept of
government is only half the battle in a
world of militants and local rule where
might makes right when it comes to the
law and in the internet age it's hard to
gain credibility when there are multiple
web pages all claiming to represent your
fledgling government piracy is a major
problem in Somalia with basically no
laws enforcement agencies to keep a lid
on things
pirate rule high seas around the country
making the water surrounding Somalia one
of the most dangerous shipping routes in
the world in 1923 the British government
decided to grant New Zealand their own
little piece of the ice encrusted
Antarctic wasteland
they established the Ross dependency New
Zealand a little cheese shaped triangle
of Antarctica which included a swath of
the continent and also extended out into
the sea to cover a small archipelago
known as the Balinese Islands to date
New Zealand hasn't quite figured out
what to do with them there has been no
attempt thus far to establish a colony
on the islands though still technically
under the governance of New Zealand if
there is a bright Center to civilization
then the Balinese islands are certainly
far from it though the Antarctica act of
1960 established a precedent for
prosecuting criminal acts in the Ross
dependency
it doesn't seem anyone is actually
willing to make the trip out there to
actually enforce the law the closest
anyone in New Zealand has actually come
to acknowledging the Balinese islands
existence was a proposal to establish
them as a Marine Preserve in May of 1999
that's pretty much the equivalent of
saying well we can't quite figure out
what to do with them and perhaps we
should just leave them to the Penguins
and fish even within the United States
there are certain places that escape the
roving guy of the law located in an arid
expanse of the Sonoran Desert in
Southern California
slab city is one such place where people
go when they really want to get away
from it all
officially the site is owned by the
state of California though it is small
and desolate enough to avoid close
scrutiny by the government built on the
remnants of an old military barracks
slab city is named for the large
concrete slabs left behind after the
barracks was demolished most of the
residents live in RVs campers and tents
amidst shanty structures that serve as
meeting places for music and community
gatherings though they purchased most of
their supplies from a nearby town
thus lovers pride themselves on their
self-sufficiency choosing to go without
many modern luxuries in exchange for the
freedom that slab city offers
called the last free place on earth by
its inhabitants the population of mostly
hippies and plain old weirdos fluctuates
with the seasons from the 150 or so
permanent residents to nearly two
thousand people during peak moves some
are attracted to the weather others the
isolation but all enjoy the rare
opportunity to experience a lifestyle
free from the burden of regulation and
rules free at least until the state of
California demands the Lund back last
but certainly not least is Pitcairn
Island in the Southern Pacific Ocean
with a population of only 48 people as
of a July 2014 estimate it is the
smallest national jurisdiction in the
world by population on an island of only
47 square kilometers that means there
isn't much room to spread your legs so
you better hope you don't make any
enemies whilst you're there
Pitcairn Island and the unpopulated
Island around it are claimed as a
British overseas territory by the United
Kingdom because we all know how much the
UK just lost a stick flight into things
and say it's theirs though the residents
of Pitcairn Island bend their knee to
the crown ruler they've been allowed to
establish a local Parliament to handle
matters on the island via representative
democracy essentially the Islanders are
left alone to craft their own laws and
self govern as long as the Queen can
peek over their shoulder now inland
despite Britain's claim to Pitcairn
Island and its surrounds the United
Nations still considers the area to be a
non-self-governing territory with so few
people involved in the democratic
process it must be difficult to cast
votes objectively vote for the wrong
person and you just might have your
dinner burn that night thanks for the
view subscribe for more four-seater
you